Fisherman rib is a beautiful ribber
technique that incorporates
tuck on both needle beds.
For machines that have this ribber
carriage, it can be problematic to knit
fisherman rib, but it's not impossible.
If you've used other knitting machines
this feature of this machine
is a little different.
Take a moment to explore how this
carriage works on your machine.
Disconnect the ribber carriage
from the coupler and move the main
bed carriage out of the way.
Pull a few needles all
the way out to hold position.
Pass the carriage back and forth.
Notice that the needles do not engage. No
matter what knitting you
have on the ribber carriage.
Those needles do not move.
Look at the side of the carriage and
locate this small, somewhat hidden lever.
Hold the lever up with your finger or
a tool and slowly pass the carriage across
the needles and you'll see that the
needles engage and they will now knit.
Looking at the underside of the carriage
will give you a visual of this.
With the levers in their default position,
the needle butts travel through this
neutral channel and they're
not going to move or knit.
But by forcing the needle butts through
this channel with the little lever,
the needles will now knit
now just as a point of interest.
While we're looking at the underside
of the carriage,
when the needles are in working or middle
position, they'll travel through these
channels for regular knitting and slip.
So how do you work fisherman
rib on this machine?
Cast on for 1x1 ribbing.
End with your carriage on the right.
Set your main bed carriage
to tuck or hold to the left.
By setting the left Cam lever to H.
It's going to remain in this position.
So your left Cam lever is at H.
Your right Cam lever is at N for regular
knitting on your main bed carriage.
Next, set the ribber for plain knitting.
Work the setup row.
Pull  the main bed needles all the way out
to hold position and knit to the left.
The main bed needles will tuck
and the ribber needles will knit.
The stitch pattern is worked
in two steps over two rows.
Step one, you've got your
carriage on your left.
Pull the ribber needles all
the way out to hold position.
Knit to the right.
Remember, the main bed is
set to knit to the right.
Step two, with the carriage on the right,
pull the main bed needles out to hold.
Now notice now all
the needles are out to hold.
But this time we're going to force those
held ribber needles to knit by holding
that little side lever up so it
clears the butts of the needles.
When you knit to the left,
those ribbing needles are going to knit
and the main bed needles will hold.
Repeat steps one and two
for the length of your knitting.
Let's go back to step one.
The carriage is on the left.
Pull the ribber needles all the way out
to hold position so all your needles are
in hold position, but your main
bed is set to knit to the right.
Knit to the right, your main bed
needles knit. Your ribber needles
hold. Step two.
Your carriage is on the right.
Pull all the main bed
needles to hold. Again,
all those needles are in hold.
Force those held ribbing needles
to knit by holding the side lever up,
knit to the left.
The main bed needles will hold
the ribbing needles will knit.
Continue to do this for the
length of your knitting.
Now notice that you're not changing any
carriage settings as you're knitting
except for holding that little lever up.
When you want the ribber needles to knit.
Something to keep in mind.
If you're knitting with your ribber
and you want to work short rows,
this little lever comes into play again.
The only way to get needles that are all
the way out on the ribber to knit is
to hold that little lever up and force
the needle butts through the channel
so the needles will knit.
Knitting fisherman Rib
on this machine isn't hard.
It's just different than other machines.
Have fun with Fisherman.
Rib Other Ribbing variations.